From one town to the next, Ukrainian civilians continue to run away from Russian bombs,...
...leaving their homes behind with just a few possessions.
So far, efforts to create a humanitarian corridor have failed.
Monday, the Kremlin announced that a ceasefire...
...over six routes started at 10:00 A.M. Moscow time.
Detailed information about the humanitarian corridors...
...was brought to the attention of the Ukrainian's side in advance,...
...as well as to the UN, the OSCE and the Red Cross.
Four of the six destinations proposed by Moscow are in Russian or Belarusian territory.
Ukrainian officials called the offer an immoral stunt.
As ceasefire talks continue between Ukrainians and Russians,...
...families attempt to find shelter.
The UN estimates that in just the past ten days,...
...more than 1.7 million people have managed to cross into neighboring countries,...
...making this the fastest-growing refugee crisis in Europe since the Second World War.